voilà des semaines que les habitants de
la petite hollande passe des nuits
difficiles ce matin au marché très peu
d'habitants accepte de réagir à notre
micro
c'est des fous ça des jeunes c'est des
jeunes qui viennent leurs billets parce
que les vous expliquer ça ils sont
poussés par les anciens des gars de 25
30 ans il fait pas si les drogues chez
les wade les manipulent
et puis ils les font une aire l'onu qui
ne font que passer des jeunes soupçonnés
d'avoir incendié deux voitures dans la
nuit de dimanche à lundi
elles s'ajoutent aux sept voitures
brûlées lors du 14 juillet dernier la
mairie a instauré un couvre-feu pour les
moins de 16 ans une mesure peu respecté
ces individus continuent d'effrayer les
habitants je vous dis franchement qu'on
a peur tous les jours maintenant tous
les soirs quand on va se coucher on en a
peur que ça revienne
enfin nous on a dit dans ce quartier lac
est un petit peu plus cher si vous
voulez il ya quand même eu des voitures
qui ont été saccagés on a eu nos
poubelles ont été incendiées aussi
plusieurs de mes voisines et moi on a
n'a peur vraiment car à jour y mettent
le feu à nous à nos appartements
les pompiers interviennent seulement si
les feux risque de se propager aux
habitations
la police elle aussi limiterait son
activité sur le terrain les gens disent
que la police n'intervient plus la
police ne monte plus la nuit pour pas
recréer d'autres conflits je pense pour
pas enflammé encore plus les voitures
gramat on sait que c'est les voitures de
de gens qui ont besoin pour aller
travailler donc qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que voilà
les gens je pense qu'ils en ont marre
ils demandent comment ça va se finir
le commissariat de police n'a pas voulu
communiquer sur le sujet la ville a
refusé notre demande d'interview mais la
mer souligne que les renforts de police
sont nécessaires pour faire respecter ce
couvre-feu
en espérant que cela ramène le calme
dans le quartier